und jetzt das heute journal
guten Abend immer im Februar tagt in
München die Sicherheitskonferenz im
noblen Bayerischen Hof diskutieren
Regierungschefs und Chefinnen
verteidigungs- und außenpolitikerinnen
Sicherheitsexperten und Vertreter der
Rüstungsindustrie über die Weltlage
letzten Februar wenige Tage vor Putins
Überfall auf die Ukraine bei der
russische Außenminister Sergej lavroff
noch eingeladen kam aber nicht dieses
Jahr ist laborf als Gast nicht mehr
erwünscht ein Dialog mit Russland
scheint unmöglich stattdessen aber gibt
es den Versuch moskauss Unterstützer zu
beeinflussen Chinas top-diplomat
jedenfalls nahm die Einladung nach
München an Matthies fällt oft berichtet
die Wichtigkeit der Weltenlenker ist
mitunter an der Vielzahl ihrer Entourage
zu erkennen Chinas Chef aus dem
Politiker waren die und seine Delegation
Wissen um ihre Stärke und ihre Position
es wird irgendwie paradox das dem
Vertreter der chinesischen Diktatur am
ehesten zugetraut wird dem russischen
Diktator in den Arm zu fallen und Wang
weiß wie man diesen Mythos Nahrung gibt
wenn eine sichere Welt ist die
Souveränität und territoriale Integrität
aller Länder etwas das geachtet werden
muss
Machtpolitik und Hegemonie sind das
Rezept für globale Instabilität und dies
verursacht den größten Schaden am
weltweiten Frieden
hochrechnet was der Saal als
Friedensbotschaft in Sachen Ukraine
begreift ist für wann vor allem auch
eine Drogen Richtung Taiwan
der Chinese entzieht sich der westlichen
Sichtweise auch weil er trotz aller
Betreuung und friedensbotschaften immer
wieder auch das russische narrativ
befeuert können
möglicherweise gibt es einige Kräfte
denen sind Friedensgespräche nicht recht
denen ist das Leben der Ukraine
vielleicht legal
gemeint sind die USA die Beziehung
zwischen den Großmächten sind derzeit
denkbar schlecht für die amerikanische
Vizepräsidentin ist die chinesische
Friedensbotschaft ein reiner Propaganda
Trick und Kamala Herres warnt die
Chinesen bloß nicht weiter zu gehen bei
der Unterstützung Russlands
jeder Schritt Chinas Russland mit
tödlichen Waffen zu unterstützen würde
die Aggression nur belohnen
das Töten fortsetzen
auch wenn es zunächst so aussieht als ob
man mal wieder vor allem über die
Ukraine redet sind die Vertreter Kiews
inzwischen fester Bestandteil aller
Gespräche alte Fehler will keiner
wiederholen eine Umarmung der deutschen
Außenministerin eine Umarmung des
Amerikaners die Versicherung sich nicht
spalten zu lassen ist das feste
Versprechen des Westens
ich denke die wichtigste und
wirkungsvollste Sicherheitsgarantie wäre
wenn man ganz klar und fest an den Sieg
der Ukraine
believe in the victory of you doch dafür
weiter Waffen zu liefern das geht für
Tausende von Demonstranten
unterschiedlicher heute in München nicht
solch eine Bedingung als Voraussetzung
für einen Frieden scheint aber eher
unrealistisch
diese Art von Frieden würde bedeuten
dass wir die Menschen in der Ukraine an
Russland ausliefern würden und das würde
auch bedeuten
das ist das Ende der internationalen
Ordnung und das Ende des internationalen
Rechts ist zum Schluss sind es wieder
die einfachen Gesten Außenminister die
sich umarmen weil sie wissen dass gerade
im Kampf um Frieden Symbole nicht zu
unterschätzen sind
Ulf beobachtet die Sicherheitskonferenz
in München und hat zuvor für ZDF aus
Peking berichtet Ulf guten Abend wie ist
diese Friedensinitiative der
chinesischen Führung einzuschätzen kann
China in diesem Konflikt überhaupt als
ehrlicher Makler auftreten
zumindestens wollen die Chinesen als
ehrlicher Makler gesehen werden das ist
die Rolle diese gerne spielen würden und
die haben sie auch versucht hier auf der
Sicherheitskonferenz auf dieser großen
Bühne zu spielen sie wollen als
moralische Weltmacht wahrgenommen werden
die eben versucht Frieden zu schaffen
eben Gegensatz zum Westen die ja über
Kampfpanzer und Kampfjets diskutiert und
ich glaube es gibt noch eine weiteren
strategischen Grund für die Chinesen sie
wollen testen wie groß die Solidarität
des Westens wirklich mit der Ukraine ist
die Chinesen rechnen so ein bisschen das
irgendwann in den westlichen
Gesellschaften eine gewisse Demokratie
als eine gewisse Kriegsmüdigkeit
entsteht die Antwort ist heute von den
Amerikanern gekommen vor wenigen Stunden
haben sich der chinesische Außenminister
waren je und der amerikanischen der
blinken getroffen man nennt das ein
Geheimtreffen aber was rausgekommen ist
von den Amerikanern ist doch sehr
deutlich blinken hat noch mal sehr stark
die Chinesen kritisiert und hat vor
allem gesagt es gibt diese eine rote
gehen hier wenn China Waffen an die
Russland liefert dann wird es wirklich
Ärger geben also das war kein charmantes
treffen und so muss man wahrscheinlich
sagen heute Abend hier bei der
menschheitskonferenz stehen die Zeichen
eher auf Schwierigkeiten diese Welt
möchte sind doch beides sich sehr
feindlich verbunden okay keine positiven
Aussichten bislang ultra war das aus
München vielen Dank
ein Ziel des neuen Chefs der Münchner
Sicherheitskonferenz Christoph Heusgen
ist es den Blick über Europa und Amerika
hinaus zu weiten viel zu lange habe sich
die Tagung engstirnig auf den Westen
konzentriert und dabei den Süden
vernachlässigt zu besichtigen ist das in
diesen Tagen in Afrika dort halten
Russland China und Südafrika ein
gemeinsames Militärmanöver ab
ausgerechnet um den ersten Jahrestag des
ukrainekriegs herum die Botschaft ist
klar Russland und China sein anders als
die Europäer die wahren Freunde des
afrikanischen Kontinents Susann von
Lojewski berichtet
die russisch-orthodoxe Kirche am
Stadtrand von Johannesburg jeden Tag
beten hier Russen und auch Ukraine
gemeinsam der Krieg ist weit weg und am
liebsten möchten sie hier nicht darüber
reden
[Musik]
in der Kirche sprechen wir nicht darüber
oder diskutieren ich bin für Russland
ich bin aus der Ukraine das würden wir
nicht tun es gibt etwas Höheres als
unsere menschlichen Themen
things human
gut 500 Kilometer weiter vor der Küste
Durbans sprechen Militärs eine andere
Sprache Südafrika Russland und China
halten ein gemeinsames marienmanöver ab
aktuelle Bilder nicht erwünscht vor
wenigen Tagen noch wurde die Fregatte
Admiral goschkov in Kapstadt aufgetankt
angeblich ist sie mit nuklearfähigen
Hyperschall Raketen bestückt
Professor irina philatova hat lange an
der Uni Dörpen gelehrt und weiß warum
Moskau jetzt neue Freunde am Kap sucht
die Beziehungen mit Europa sind komplett
zerstört die Beziehungen mit den USA
sind zerstört Russland braucht neue
Handelspartner und das braucht neue
Partner in der geopolitischen Situation
das Südafrika ist neuer Partner gerne
zur Verfügung steht hat viel mit der
Vergangenheit zu tun im Kampf gegen das
Apartheid-Regime hat die frühere
Sowjetunion den 1c die Parteien Nelson
Mandelas finanziell und militärisch
unterstützt
auch tarnen tentini war als junger
Einzelkämpfer zur Ausbildung in Moskau
eine Zeit die ihm auch Jahrzehnte später
viel bedeutet
wir betrachten die Russen immer noch als
die die uns geholfen haben und die an
unserer Seite standen in den
schwierigsten Zeiten als wir gegen die
Apartheid kämpften und das können wir
nicht einfach
ignorieren
das auch die Ukraine einmal Teil der
Sowjetunion war vergessen selbst die
jüngere Generation aber sie Südafrika
als Freund Russlands
neokomagoman war Studentin Moskau als
der Krieg ausbrach er spricht aus was
viele Junge auf dem Kontinent denken
aber der Krieg der gerade im Kongo und
Ruanda tobt der größte Krieg gerade
darüber spricht niemand
Südafrika blickt anders auf den Ukraine
Krieg das zu begreifen ist die
Herausforderung für den Westen
und hier geht es jetzt weiter mit Heinz
Wolf und Nachrichten aus dem
Erdbebengebiet zwölf Tage nach dem
verheerenden Beben konnten die Helfer in
Hatay in der Türkei noch zwei
verschüttete retten
Einsatzkräfte befreiten sie aus den
Trümmern und brachten sie zur Versorgung
ins Krankenhaus die Hoffnung weitere
verschüttete Leben zu finden schwindet
aber immer mehr die Zahl der Todesopfer
wird in der Türkei inzwischen mit mehr
als 40.000 angegeben in Syrien sind es
bisher fast 6000 die un-hilfe für die
Überlebenden läuft inzwischen auch im
schwer betroffenen Nordwesten Syriens an
der nicht vom Assassin kontrolliert wird
wenn sie spenden möchten das
Aktionsbündnis Katastrophenhilfe hat die
IBAN
de65100-400-100-400 Stichwort ZDF
Erdbeben Türkei Syrien Informationen
finden Sie auch auf
spenden.zdf.de und im ZDF Text auf Seite
kurz vor einem gemeinsamen Manöver der
USA und Südkoreas hat Nordkorea erneut
eine Langstreckenrakete getestet nach
Angaben der südkoreanischen Militärs
handelte es sich um eine Rakete die auch
atomare Sprengköpfe tragen könnte sie
sei auf japanische mehr abgefeuert
worden und nach etwa 900 km ins Meer
gestürzt nordkorea hatte gestern mit
beispiellosen Militäraktionen gedroht
wenn die USA und Südkorea das gemeinsame
Militärmanöver abhalten
ein Drohbrief an die grüne
verkehrssenatorin in Berlin jarasch hat
parteiübergreifend Empörung ausgelöst
die regierende spd-bürgermeisterin
Giffey sagte jemanden wegen seiner
politischen Überzeugungen mit Hass und
Drohungen zu überziehen überschreite
jede Grenze nach Angaben giffeis war in
dem Brief ein Jahr rasch auch eine
revolverpatrone der Staatsschutz
ermittelt
nachdem in Bulgarien gestern in einem
Lastwagen 18 Migranten tot aufgefunden
wurden haben die Behörden sieben
Personen festgenommen die Ermittler
vermuten dass ein schleuserring die aus
Afghanistan stammenden Migranten in das
EU-Land Bulgarien gebracht hatte die
Toten wurden in einem außerhalb von
Sofia abgestellten Lastwagen entdeckt
nach ersten Erkenntnissen waren sie in
dem Versteck unter einer Holzladung
erstickt 34 Überlebende wurden
medizinisch versorgt
und auch das gab es am Rande der
Münchner Sicherheitskonferenz ein
Treffen von 11 außenministerinnen die
die Diskriminierung von Frauen in
Afghanistan scharf kritisierten und sich
mit den demonstrantenen in Iran
solidarisch erklärten dort sind die
Proteste in den letzten Tagen wieder
aufgeflammt unterstützt von einer
internationalen Koalition von Exil
Iranern zum ersten Mal könnte es
gelungen sein die Opposition außerhalb
Irans zu vereinen einen erheblichen
Anteil daran hat es moilion der im
Oktober die riesige solidaritätsdemo in
Berlin mit organisierte und schon als
Übergangspräsident nach einem möglichen
Sturz der Mullahs gehandelt wird Kamera
und safarian hat ihn in Toronto
getroffen
Januar 2020 ein ukrainisches
Passagierflugzeug wird kurz nach dem
Start in Tehran abgeschossen erst nach
Tagen gibt das Regime den Abschuss zu
176 Menschen sterben
ein Tag den Hamed esmoil Leonie
vergessen wird denn beim Abschluss von
Flug PS 752 kommen seine Frau und seine
einzige Tochter ums Leben
dieses Verbrechen hat mein Leben
zerstört an einem Tag wie heute würde
ich mit meiner Familie essen und mit
meiner Tochter spielen
was mich neben dem Verlust meiner
liebsten am meisten Schmerz ist diese
grausame Ungerechtigkeit sie ist die
Grundlage für mein Krieg gegen das
Regime
ein Krieg den erstmaligion vom
kanadischen Toronto auskämpft er
arbeitet als Zahnarzt gleichzeitig
organisiert er von seiner Praxis aus die
iranische auslands-opposition als
Führungsfigur hat er die verfeindeten
Oppositionsgruppen vereint im letzten
Jahr mobilisierte er hunderttausende
weltweit zu Protestmärschen jetzt gibt
es wieder Proteste in Iran esmaillon und
andere Oppositionelle haben zuletzt ein
Bündnis geschmiedet für die Zeit nach
dem Sturz der Mulas
erfolgreich sein wird darf es keine
Rache oder straßenjustiz geben die
Todesstrafe muss aufgehoben werden all
jene die einen Verbrechen des Regimes
beteiligt sind der Revolutionsführer die
todesrichter oder Polizeikräfte sollten
sich vor Gericht verantworten ich denke
das beste Beispiel dafür sind die
Nürnberger Prozesse
wir begleiten ist Marion zu einer Gedenk
Veranstaltung für einen getöteten
Demonstranten im Iran viele
opferangehörige sehen in ihm einen
künftigen Präsidenten in Iran so mahnt
er werden immer noch täglich Menschen
inhaftiert und gefoltert daher dürfe der
Westen nicht wegschauen
der Westen schließt die Augen vor den
Verbrechen in Iran die Ignoranz ist weit
verbreitet
der Westen blamiert sich doch wenn er
mit Iran verhandelt statt die
revolutionsgarten auf die Terrorliste zu
nehmen oder seine Botschafter aus Iran
abzuziehen denn die Menschen in Iran
wollen dieses Regime nicht mehr
will Gerechtigkeit für Iran und den
immer noch ungeklärten Abschuss der
ukrainischen Maschine
er will Iran vor den Internationalen
Gerichtshof ziehen das gibt im Kraft so
sagt er den Tod seiner Familie zu
verkraften
dann hat der Themenwechsel zu den
Lottozahlen dieses samstags sie lauten
wie immer ohne Gewähr 7 28 36 40 43 49
Superzahl 8 weitere Gewinnzahlen finden
sie auf lotto.zdf.de und im ZDF Text auf
Seite 556
die Wetteraussichten morgen wird es von
Nordrhein-Westfalen bis nach Bayern
häufig regnen sonst bleibt es meist
trocken vor allem im Norden kann es auch
länger freundlich sein bei einem starken
Westwind werden 5 bis 14 Grad erreicht
am Rosenmontag und am Faschingsdienstag
gibt es in der Mitte und im Süden viel
Sonne im Norden Wolken und etwas Regen
mit 8 bis 17 Grad ist es sehr mild am
Aschermittwoch wird es von Westen her
unbeständiger
das war's von uns am schnellen
Samstagabend hier geht's jetzt weiter
mit dem Aktuellen Sportstudio und Katrin
Müller-Hohenstein und danach um 0:25
meldet sich dann Fahrer Schlink mit der
nächsten heute Express in einen schönen
Abend und bis morgen tschüss
[Musik]